for most of the history in the United
States the government was about 10% of
the economy most of it state and local
not federal and now if you count the
cost of the regulatory state it's more
than a half of the economy
the number of laws made in the Congress
has not really increased significantly
in a hundred years Congress still works
kind of the way it always worked so the
point is the government's got really big
and some of the arguments for that are
the ones I just named right there are
crying needs it's one country
environmental harm goes over borders
smog and stuff like that so there are
arguments that there are crying public
needs and the government should address
them do you think there's flexibility in
the Constitution to meet that argument
Emily has stated that she has an opinion
about that explain that Emily uh yes so
I think that public needs and how that
fits into the Constitution is related to
the debate that goes back to James
Madison versus Alexander Hamilton and
the interpretation of the Constitution
for example they debated over whether or
not the general welfare phrase in the
Constitution was an extra power that was
given to the government or whether or
not it was a summary of the previously
named powers and Hamilton so there's an
article one section eight where the
Constitution says roughly that it can
tax and spend I think it says for the
general welfare and if memory serves
James Madison actually argues that that
clause was badly written because what
they had in mind was that they could tax
and spend to pay off the debts that the
states had incurred in the revolution as
long as those debts were incurred
in the general cause of winning the
Revolutionary War and Hamilton read it
as we can do more stuff and Madison's
counter that was okay why do we have a
list then of things we can do why is it
say you can do these things if you can
also do anything else that promotes the
general welfare how does that make any
sense and Emily is a Hamiltonian that's
she's a big government girl and and you
know she is by the way the very problem
that we face and the loss of our freedom
now there's something to it though right
because epidemic or a pandemic
you'd have to fight that nationally
somehow and maybe you could do that by
cooperation among the states and so what
Emily indicated is a Prudential argument
you're gonna build up this government
and it's gonna be supreme for national
purposes but only for they and the
unspoken part is national political
purposes things that have to be done for
the nation to be a free nation and well
governed right that's one kind of
argument right and that argument has
gone on from the beginning and there's
been more than one view about it among
people who were however very friendly to
the idea that there are limits on the
government and they mean something and
they can't be breached because it has to
remain a liberal society and by liberal
they just mean that you know if you're
gonna have all the sovereignty out here
in this big circle it needs to be pretty
big if it's gonna control something as
powerful as a government without being
in the government so that little circle
has got to be a lot littler than
everything else and in economic terms it
isn't anymore that's about the same size